i have a function f of x here and i want
to think about which of these curves
could represent f prime of x could
represent the derivative of f of x
well to think about that we just have to
think about what is the slope of the
tangent line doing at each point of f of
x and see if this corresponds to that
slope if the value of these functions
correspond to that slope
so we can see when x is equal to
negative 4 the slope of the tangent line
is essentially vertical so you could say
it's not really defined there but as we
go slightly to the right of x equals
negative 4 we just have a very very very
positive slope so you could kind of view
it as our slope is going from infinity
to very very positive to a little bit
less positive to a little bit less
positive to a little bit less positive
to a little bit less positive so which
of these graphs here have that property
remember this is trying to graph the
slope so which of these which of these
functions down here which of these
graphs should have a value that is
essentially kind of approaching infinity
and when x is equal to negative negative
four and then it gets less and less and
less positive as x goes to zero
so this one it looks like it's coming
from negative infinity it's getting less
and less and less negative so that
doesn't seem to meet our constraints
this one looks like it is coming from a
positive infinity and it's getting less
and less and less positive so that seems
to be okay
this has the same property it's getting
less and less and less positive
this one right over here starts very
negative and gets less and less and less
negative so we can rule that out
now let's think about what happens let's
think about what happens when x gets to
zero when x gets to zero
the tangent line is horizontal we're at
a maximum point of this curve right over
here a slope the slope of a horizontal
line is zero
and so which one of these remember we're
trying to look for which one of these
curves represent the value of that slope
so which one of these curves hit zero
when x is equal to zero
well this one doesn't so the only
candidate that we have left is this one
and this one does hit zero when x equals
zero and let's see if it keeps
satisfying what we need for f prime of x
so after that point it should start
getting more and more negative the slope
should get more and more and more
negative essentially approaching
negative infinity negative infinity as x
approaches 4. and we see that here the
this value of this function is getting
more and more negative and it's
approaching negative infinity as x
approaches 4. so we'll go with this one
this looks like a pretty good candidate
for f prime of x